Ecoute...
J'aimerais pouvoir t'aider...
Mais pour ça va falloir que tu me donne un nom
Ca te semble être dans tes cordes ?
REPOND !!
Ou... ouais ok !
Café ?
Eu.. ouais je veux bien !
Avec du sucre ?
Ouais !
Tu me dis stop ?
STOP..
Avec du lait?
Ouais
Ouuu !
Bon !
Maintenant tu vas me dire quelque chose, gamin!
La CANELLE !
Ça te dirais ça un petit peu de cannelle ?!
RÉPONDS !
Bah oui!
'Fin je veux dire... Je suis pas contre
J'imagine que tu veux quelque chose a grignoter avec?
Spéculos? Crêpes? Pancakes?
Un p'tit nuage de chocolat ?
SPÉCULOS, CRÊPES, PANCAKES, NUAGE DE CHOCOLAT?!
Du chocolat, du chocolat !
AVEC DE LA CRÈME DE MARRON?
RÉPONDS !
DES PETITES NOIX DE CAJOUS ?!
RÉPONDS, PUTAIN !
DES NOISETTES, QUELQUES NOISETTES ?!
DES NOISETTES?! RÉPONDS !
OUI BAH OUI, BAH PEUT ETRE JE SAIS PAS, OUI!
CRUMBLE, CA TE FERAIS PLAISIR CA DU CRUMBLE ?!
RÉPONDS, FILS DE PUTE !
DONNE MOI UN NOM PUTAIN!
RÉPONDS !
QUOI ?!
TON PRENOM?!
GREG !
Je m’appelle Greg ...
Bah voila!
Quand tu veux!
Allez dégage ...
DÉGAGE !
Alors?
Bah alors le café est bon...
Mais le service heu...
Mais le service heu... C'est un peu ...